how do we get people engaged in solving
global warming I'd like to start with
running to shorts experiments with you
all so your task is to notice if you
feel any difference as I speak okay here
we go
we are seeing rising carbon dioxide
levels now about 410 PPM's to avoid the
RCP eight-point-five scenario we need
rapid decarbonisation the global carbon
budget for 66% likelihood to meet the
two-degree target is approximately 800
gigatons
okay now let me try something else we
are huh we are heading for an
uninhabitable earth monster storms
killer floods devastating wildfires
crazy heat waves that will cook us under
a Blazing Sun 2017 is already so
unexpectedly warm it's freaking out
climate scientists we have a three year
window to cut emissions three years if
not we'll soon live in a boiling earth a
hellhole okay so now your task how did
these ways of speaking make you feel the
first detached maybe or just confused
with this guy talking about the other
fearful or just numb so again the
question asked how do we get people
engaged in solving global warming and
why don't these two ways of
communicating work you see the biggest
obstacle to dealing with climate
disruptions lies between your ears
building on a rapidly growing body of
psychology and social science I spent
years looking into the five inner
defenses that stop people from engaging
when people hear news about the climate
coming straight at them the first
defense comes up rapidly distance when
we hear about the climate we hear about
something far away in space think arctic
ice polar bears far away in time think
2100 it's huge and slow-moving think
gigatons and centuries so it's not here
it's not now since it feels so far away
from me it seems outside my circle of
influence so I feel helpless about it
there's nothing I can do in our everyday
lives most of us prefer to think about
narrow things such as our jobs our kids
how many likes we get
Facebook now that that's real next
defense is doom climate change is
usually framed as a looming disaster
bringing losses costs and sacrifice that
makes us fearful but after the first
fear is gone my brain soon wants to
avoid this topic altogether after 30
years of scary climate change
communications more than 80% of media
articles still use disaster framings but
people have bit to it too and then
desensitize to doom overuse so many of
us are now suffering a kind of
apocalypse fatigue getting numb from too
much collapse porn the third offense is
dissonance now if what we know that
fossil fuel use contributes to global
warming conflicts with what we do drive
fly eat beef then so called cognitive
dissonance sets in this is felt as an
inner discomfort we may feel like
hypocrites to get rid of this discomfort
our brain starts coming up with
justifications so I can say for instance
my neighbor he has a much bigger car
than I do or changing my diet doesn't
amount to anything if I am the only want
to do in it or I could even want to
doubt climate science itself I could say
you know climate is always changing so
these justification make us all feel
better but at the expense of dismissing
what we know this behavior drives
attitudes my personal cognitive
dissonance comes up when I recognize
that I've been flying from Oslo to New
York and back to Oslo in order to speak
about the climate
for fourteen minutes so that won't that
makes me want to move on to denial so if
we keep silent ignore or ridicul the
facts about climate disruptions then we
might find in a refuge from fear and
guilt denial doesn't really come from
lack of intelligence or knowledge no
denial is a state of mind in which I may
be aware of some troubling knowledge but
I'll live an act as if I don't know so
you could call it a kind of double life
both knowing and not knowing and often
this is reinforced by others my family
or community agreeing not to raise this
tricky topic
finally identity I learned climate
activists demand that government takes
action either with regulation or carbon
taxes but consider what happens when
people who hold conservative values for
instance hear from an activist that
government ought to expand even further
particularly in rich Western democracies
they are then less likely to believe
that science how's that well if I hold
conservative values for instance I
probably prefer big proper cars and
small government over twenty tiny cars
and huge government and if climate
science comes and then says government
should expand further then I'm probably
will trust that science less in this way
cultural identity starts to override the
facts the values eat the facts and my
identity Trump's truth any day
so after recognizing how these five DS
kill engagement how can we move beyond
them new research shows how we can flip
these five defences over into key
success criteria for a more brain
friendly climate communication
so this is where it gets really exciting
and where we find the five SS the five
evidence-based solutions for what does
work first we can flip distance to
social we can make climate feel near
personal and urgent by bringing it home
and we can do that by spreading social
norms that are positive to solutions if
I believe my friends or neighbors you
guys we do something then I will too we
can see for instance this from rooftop
solar panels they are spreading from
neighbor to neighbor like a virus it's
contagious this is the power of
peer-to-peer creating the new normal
next we can flip doom to supportive
rather than backfiring frames such as
disaster and cost we can reframe climate
as being really about human health for
instance with plant-based delicious
burgers good for you and good for the
climate we can also reframe climate as
being about new tech opportunities about
safety and about new jobs solar jobs for
instance are seeing an amazing growth
and just post the three million jobs
mark psychology says in order to create
engagement we should present on balance
three positive or supportive framings
for each climate threat we mention then
we can flip dissonance to simpler
actions this is often called nudging the
idea is but better choice architecture
we can make the climate friendly
behaviors default and convenient let me
illustrate this take food waste food
waste at the face goes way down if the
plate or the box size is reduced a
little because on the smaller plate it
looks full but in the big box it looks
half-empty so we put more in so smaller
plates make a big difference for food
waste and there are hundreds of
smart not just like this the point is
dissonance goes down as more behaviors
unmerged then we can flip denial by
tailoring signals that visualize our
progress we can provide motivating
feedback on how well we're doing with
our problem-solving say you improve your
transport footprint or cut energy waste
in your buildings then one app that can
share this well is called ducky the idea
is you log your actions there and then
you can see how well your team or
company is doing so you get real-time
signals finally identity we can flip
identity with better stories our brain
loves stories so we need better stories
of where we all want to go and we need
more stories of the heroes and heroines
of all stripes that are making real
change happen I'm proud that my hometown
of Oslo is now embarking on a bold
journey of electrifying all transport
where the cars bikes or buses this is
one of the people spearheading this is
Christina boo
she is heading the electric car
Association for years and she's been
fighting every day now UK and France
India and China have also announced
plans for ending the sales of fossil
cross now that's massive and in Oslo we
can see how enthusiastic Evo owners go
and tell their electric stories to
friends and neighbors and bring them
along so we come full circle from story
back to social so thousands of climate
communicators are now starting to use
these solutions all over the world it is
clear however that individual solutions
are not sufficient to solving climate
alone but they do build stronger
bottom-up support for policies and
solutions that can that is why engaging
people is so crucial
I started this talk with testing two
ways of communicating climate with you
there is another way too
I'd like to share with you it starts
with reimagining climate itself as the
living air climate isn't really about
some abstract distant climate far far
away from us it's about this air that
surrounds us this air you can feel in
this room to the air that moves right
now and your nostrils this air is our
Earth's skin it's amazingly thin
compared to the size of the earth and
the cosmos it shields us from far
thinner than the skin of an apple
compared to its diameter
it may look infinite when we look up but
the beautiful breathable air is only
like five to seven miles thin fragile
wrapping around a massive ball inside
this skin we're all closely connected
the breath that you just took contained
around four hundred thousand of the same
Oregon atoms that Gandhi breathed during
his lifetime inside this thing
fluctuating unsettled film all of life
is nourished protected and held it
insulates and regulates temperatures in
a range that is just right for water and
for life as we know it and mediating
between the blue ocean and black
eternity the clouds carry all the
billions of tons of water needed for the
soils the air fills the rivers stirs the
water's waters the forests with a global
weeding of the weather there are good
reasons for feeling fear and despair yet
we may first grieve
today's sorry states and losses and then
turn to face the future with sober eyes
and determination the new psychology of
climate action
lies in letting go not of science but
off the crutches of abstractions and
doom ISM and then choosing to tell the
new stories these are the stories of how
we achieve drawdown the reversing of
global warming these are the stories of
the steps we take as people's cities
companies and public bodies in caring
for the air in spite of strong headwinds
these are the stories of the steps we
take because they ground us in what we
are as humans Earthlings inside this
living air thank you
[Applause]
[Music]